so for people joining us here
um
we are talking about
a rather ambitious project and effort
to implement multi-computation and
welcome language
and
a way to think about what's going on
here is this is kind of a
a fundamental rethinking of the
evaluation process
so in our usual evaluation process
so i mean
you know standard evaluation
it has two features one
it
recurses well one it recurses through
expressions
uh in
let's say well in the depth first order
i believe that's
yes i believe that's correct
and two
it reevaluates
results
in a depth first order
the people agree with those statements
unless the only reason it doesn't do
this one
except
uh
for hold all functions for hold
functions
does that make sense to people
yeah what do you mean by re-evaluates
if i say
f and it evaluates to g
then and g evaluates h it does all of
that
so this is essentially quote spatial
space-like
this is essentially time-like
okay
we do not have and i think
hold all can be described as arbitrary
traversal order because there's nothing
decided for hold oil functions no it's
not it's outermost this one is left most
innermost and that one is is um leftmost
outermost
hole is is outermost because what it's
doing is it's gulping the arguments
first
it's going function
it might be different from that it might
have been controlled i think the point
is that you can use that to simulate any
any evaluation order that's what i was
going through that's what i was saying
that's like any traversal order you like
if we talking about that
right
and so now
oh gosh did we not invite people okay so
now we actually have this traversal
order function
right we have tree traversal order
coming in version 13
right
which is at least for trees
a specification of this but notice this
is pure recursion ordering
this is not um
did you know i'm saying it's not
reevaluation ordering
does that make sense to people
no yes
roger christopher others carlo i mean
does that make sense
does carlo know about stuff yet
the trees yeah
i saw this stuff there's i mean
there's one thing i'm a little bit
confused about maybe you could convince
me
like
all this tree traversal stuff
like
substitution order etc
isn't that
like a detail that is largely orthogonal
to like the whole ruler part of this
does it really matter or or can we just
think about this as
transformation of some kind of global
state
and then yeah it matters a lot this is
this is part of the story of defining
foliations which is what we're about to
come to
doesn't matter
no i'm not saying it doesn't matter i'm
saying is isn't that like completely
separated from the whole evaluation
graph
like
the details
no they're not
that's that's
no more disconnected than space and time
are disconnected
i mean the
look okay so so
let's just play what the you know so
is the multi-computation idea the
multi-computation idea
is also
we have
a branch-like separation that is
we have because in this one what we're
doing is you know this a key feature of
this is
we're always okay the the basic scheme
is
evaluate
quotes depth first
to reach a normal form
that's what our evaluation does
right and it reaches it does that
it does it recursing through the
expression recursing re-evaluating its
goal is to reach a normal form
that makes sense
whereas
here
we also have branch-like separation
which are different possible orderings
that these things can occur in if that
makes sense
did that make any sense
yeah it does but what does this what
does this look like if
the
underlying language is something that
has a bunch of ifs and you can take
different branches of an if statement
like
i don't think it is an if story i think
you could say okay so you could write
our pattern transformations in terms of
ifs
right instead of doing pattern
transformations you go a giant if bank
so to speak okay
but what this is saying is because we
have pattern transformations we have a
natural way to generalize to the
branch-like case
if we had a bunch of ifs we wouldn't
have a natural way to do it instead of
deterministic
i'm sorry ifs are deterministic
yeah but i mean i'm i'm saying that that
that
there are
look
the
the point also is
okay we had some examples last time i
don't know where they are um of um
like for example
oh gosh where are they um
i had a nice example of a fibonacci tree
uh where the heck is it
i mean by the way one one thing with if
it's just it's also just that i mean you
can kind of just model if as a as a hold
all function can't you i mean like
there's nothing super special about it
uh
yes
yes i don't think there's anything
special about if
i mean and and
well other than the one thing picking
one branch
yeah i think one thing that's special
about if
is that it needs a non-stand you need
some element that has a non-standard
evaluation order i think right otherwise
do you even get full computation
capability if you don't
think
what do you mean yeah like i get the
core you need to have uh you if you
didn't have if somewhere at the core
there you couldn't implement if maybe
although maybe with patterns that's not
true with curtain matching you can
absolutely implement f
absolutely you can you know combinators
have no trouble implementing if
let's see maybe this has the fibonacci
case in it
or maybe it's a practicality then i
think that
for
a lot of languages you need something
that doesn't follow standard evaluation
order
right you do but i mean that you
i mean but once you have the hold all
attribute i think that that makes it so
anything you set to hold all attribute
to can be that
that thing that doesn't follow standard
evaluation order if you know what i mean
yes absolutely
yeah okay now if you have hold on you
have it i mean it's like you have a lot
more
that's an example of fibonacci
done essentially multi-computationally
okay
what that means is
in actual fibonacci you're adding things
together
here you are simply
sort of
uh you know adding things as elements to
a set
if that makes sense
right
so what's interesting here is
in fibonacci we could do a search you
know do you ever get to
f of two or something right that's
that's like a search type thing or we
can do a different observation of this
fibonacci
evaluation
that is saying
just add up the total number of leaves
does that make sense or we could do
probabilistic you know something which
is like probabilistic programming where
we say you know we try to address the
question
uh you know
we say all these different branches are
different probabilities and we simply
say what's the measure on the space of
f1's f2s at the end point so to speak
does that make sense to people
one could but why would one
so to speak
well i mean if the goal is to get f7
um i i know but the whole point is this
is just an example of
you know
a thing to realize is
okay the thing we're trying to
understand is
okay if you think about logic
programming okay if this wasn't
fibonacci's if this was i'm sure i have
another example here if this was game
configurations or something right
you know you're asking the question does
there exist one that has such such and
such a property can you derive it can
you get from this game state to this
other game state and in that case what
you're asking is does there exist a path
here as opposed to asking the question
what is the set of all possible game
states
so i'm saying
what we're trying to understand is what
multi-computation does is it gives you a
richer
version of evaluation the evaluation
that we have right now
in terms of fibonacci not what we're
doing with actual fibonacci where we're
adding all the pieces up but our analog
of the valuation for fibonacci would be
oh you get that f of one
right that is the normal form
right that we would get here does that
make sense
with our standard evaluation process
if we say these are the transformations
we can do
we will end up getting that f of one
right because we're doing the first the
way our standard evaluation works
is it gives the first transformation
that applies
does that make sense
um
okay
so now notice that
um
well this is one where we did
deduplication
where
you know where we can count paths but
where we didn't actually enumerate all
these cases
um
okay
so but but i think there was a an
earlier
comment
so do you understand do people
understand what we mean by
um
let's see
i mean
the whole point is we have a different
evaluation scheme the evaluation scheme
that we will be using right now is a
single branch down here now there is a
trickiness because there are two pieces
to that evaluation scheme
one is the recursion through expressions
and the other is of reevaluation what
we're seeing here is something much
closer to reevaluation
and what we're seeing in the recursion
through expressions is something much
more like
like if we have let's say a hypergraph
and we have multiple places we can
update it the recursion through
expressions is saying let's do that
update then this update then this update
does that make sense to people
okay
do we understand
we actually have to get some interaction
here so yeah
my first question is
like
is there a
what is it that we think that we can get
if we have a let me know
we have a multi-evaluate function yes
yes yes let me let me enumerate the
goals i thought we already did this i'm
a bit disappointed that we don't seem to
have the document from where we did this
okay first thing is
different
types of problems
being represented naturally
okay so an example is logic programming
okay
where it's it's like state of goal
given a given a goal
and certain moves
you know can you reach
a
a conclusion right that's one case being
able to represent that naturally so that
is so that
let's list the things which are like
that np problems things that are
generally of that character
they're improving okay same same story
they're improving we've got chemical
synthesis we've got a bunch of these
things where you basically give it
that where where you give it a set of
moves and its goal is to find a winning
path
does that make sense to people
what about something like a like a sat
solving problem
yes that's the same thing i mean that's
that's in the category of you know
what would the moves be i don't know i
mean maybe just like setting some
variable in some ways maybe i think so i
mean you've got a tree in the sat solver
you've got a tree of possible values for
all those variables and i agree that but
go ahead
but one thing like logic programming
they migrated away from their own
unification algorithm and started to use
linear programming and other efficient
solvers
we have a lot of declarative functions
where you give a goal and we solve it
and for that solving yes we go straight
through in many cases and do not use a
set solver more efficient we can even
count some of these things yes
absolutely okay what i what do i think
this architecture is going to look like
okay i think in the end we'll have a
multi-evaluate
and in multi-evaluate you will be able
to write in the style of logic
programming you know you can figure out
the eight queens problem by just giving
the moves
and the goal
see what i'm saying
i now and and with if you if you
i didn't do much of this but you had to
give cuts and other things
to guide it okay
yes i'm aware i'm aware i know i know
the point is and some of that stuff
right so so
okay let me let me um
the whole okay
let's just give the bigger picture for a
second okay so one thing
is you're finding one path okay that is
the traditional version of this kind of
non-deterministic computation you find
one path
okay
okay what are some other examples
another example
is some
another type of example another type of
thing
you know modernization you find the best
one
so you've sorted them all and ordered
them okay so you're right you're right
so one one thing is
um one thing here that we might list is
you know uh find a path with a property
with a with a local locally determinable
property
okay so by the way i mean is the basic
point of that category just that i mean
i don't know there's a whole i mean
i mean like roger was saying i mean we
have like you know probably
several different solvers the linear
programming stuff there's the other
convex
convex optimization stuff there's sat
solving is the basic point that there'd
be
one function that in a similar way to
how solve you know i think now we'll
call linear programming stuff if it
thinks it's appropriate you know will
you you have some standard way of
expressing the problem and then it will
kind of figure out what type of solvent
would translate it yes and so on
this is but this is just the starting
gate because this is the this is the
very traditional limiting case of
multi-computation
right i'm just saying i mean i think
that already is a fairly that would be a
very cool function to have it's also
probably fairly complicated and i think
the design of how you would actually
specify things
well i agree yeah whatever i mean that
yeah i agree with it but but we could
imagine okay the function that we can
imagine doing is a pure pattern matching
function right so in other words the the
the the thing would be let's say it's
called multi-evaluate it won't be called
exactly that because it needs i wish we
had the notes from the previous time i'm
really upset that we don't have these
maybe somebody could go back and try and
find this
um
so you know it's going to be
a set of rules basically
it's going to be some set of inits
and
then
and that will be generating essentially
this kind of thing internally
conceptually it's generating that goal
okay here's the thing though right i
think that the much more useful function
is the one that conceptually is doing
that but actually it's translating it
into a sat solver problem absolutely
absolutely absolutely because what i'm
going to explain is that then then what
we have to do is there is an observer
here
okay and the observer this is
the space of everything that can happen
the full game tree okay the observer and
i only got through the very first part
here
one of the the most trivial observer is
an observer who only notices the path
that has a particular property
okay so another possibility would be
essentially the probabilistic
programming case
where the observer
um
you know
basically is just measuring the
probabilities for lots of outcomes
and
then the other cases which i admit are
more complicated
are the cases that are like quantum
mechanics for example quantum observers
which is a different kind of observer of
the same type of thing it's an observer
you know it's it's different reference
frames it's it's observers
okay so i mean part of the motivation
for this is i've got this big list
of types of systems that i think can be
modeled with multi-computation but what
you get out when you model them that way
let me just pull that list up what you
get out when you model them that way is
not
okay let me let me give some examples
here so so
um
let's
right go see this hold on one second
um
okay so this is my list
uh
meta mathematics chemistry molecular
biology evolutionary biology
neuroscience immunology linguistics
economics machine learning and
distributed computing
okay
so
what does one imagine doing here right
so in molecular biology
what i imagine
um
you know this is a particular model for
what's going on in molecular biology
where basically what's happening is
those events
are interactions between molecules well
this particular one is very interesting
because it's consuming one molecule and
producing two molecules but i could have
another one here where it's consuming
two molecules and producing two
molecules let's say
and the whole point is that
there are different things you can
observe about what happens there one
thing you can observe is the
concentration of a type of molecule
another thing you can observe that i
don't understand as well is various
motifs
in the space-time structure so to speak
that may turn out to be significant
so
go ahead you were kind of thinking i'm
guessing that you're thinking that
one would
behind the scenes would be something
that's very efficient at sampling this
or getting sort of a path
depends on the observer it depends i
mean you know but so it's a different
style of programming basically for
certain classes of problems
yes but the whole point is that okay
look what we think happens in the actual
universe is that there's a ridiculous
amount of computation going on under
this uh you know
uh you know
underneath so to speak and we as
observers
are computationally bounded observers
that coarsely sample all of that
computation
okay now it turns out
that there's a way to do better than
just doing all that computation and
sampling it it's things like the laws of
physics
right things like general relativity are
a way of jumping ahead and not doing all
of that underlying computation
because
all that most of that underlying
computation is completely wasted on us
you know just like most of the motion of
molecules in a gas
or a fluid for example it's totally
wasted on us we just don't care we only
look at these large scale features
okay
i mean the somewhat more controversial
thing that's coming out is that's
probably true of mathematics as well
that is that a lot of what happens at
the level of formalized mathematics and
axiomatic kinds of processing
don't matter for lots of mathematical
purposes just like it doesn't matter
what molecular dynamics or gas is for
lots of fluid dynamics
but the issue here is to have a model an
underlying model that is this
multi-computational underlying model
of
all those possible you know fluid
dynamics configurations but the thing we
sample ends up in much higher level so
so maybe kind of an easier
i can see that maybe there's a class of
problems that are now easy to formulate
with what you're exactly that's what i'm
saying yes that is exactly what i'm
saying and i'm saying that that those
include some classic ones that we know
very well that we don't have a great you
know like logic programming for example
we've never had there's also sort of um
agent
based
yes agent-based models are the same type
of thing except agent-based models what
people do
one of the points of of of this
multi-computation idea
is rather than doing probabilistic
things where you say well the agent
might go left or right
what you say in the core
multi-computational model is the agent
does all of those things
and we are merely sampling that space of
possibilities we are sampling the
overall behavior of the system
and in quantum mechanics it's really
important the difference between
the you know what's happening inside
is
it there's sort of an integrated thing
that's happening inside and then you
sample it so quantum mechanics shows one
that sampling all the time is not the
same story as sampling only at the end
but steven on the other hand what you're
saying here with the respect of
multi-computation
sounds a lot like
the ergodic hypothesis so that might
break sometimes like the fact that
sampling
all the possible states with the right
weights is the same as you know
simulating
the the you know the
microscopic interactions yeah yeah right
look look this is not
yes look the ergotic hypothesis is an
utter fail for playing chess
right there is a particular path that
gets you to check mate or whatever
right
the egotic hypothesis just say oh all
the parts are the same
clearly not true in that case
right so
it is not the case i mean for some of
these models so i don't know what's
interesting i know what the nargotic
process is but what's their ergodic okay
so the idea is the ergotic hypothesis is
a standard concept in statistical
mechanics that says
that if you have a gas for example you
can look at a particular gas with a
particular configuration of molecules
and you can see the time evolution of
that gas those molecules will bounce
around they will take on a whole series
of configurations okay the ergolic
hypothesis says that the series of
configurations they take on
is distributed the same way as the set
of all possible configurations in the
ensemble of all possible arrangements
for the gas right so when you study
random processes you you very clearly
delineate there are some that are egotic
but some are not yeah yeah right exactly
and i mean the ergotic hypothesis is
very you know in its original
formulation was vastly more complicated
because it was not dealing with discrete
systems and had to deal with you know
bins and and you know all sorts of
issues about the continuum and so on the
ergodic hypothesis in a discrete system
is a very straightforward thing i mean
it's like like you know you you just
look at i mean you know to to give a
trivial example right you can you can
just say um
uh you know you could just say something
like nest graph of i don't know
you know i um
uh something like um you know i goes to
mod
i squared comma 77
you know
uh
i goes from zero to
zero to 76 or something um
that's not what i wanted to do i wanted
to say no i just want to say graph here
don't i just want to say graph
of that
sorry i meant this
um
okay so this is a non-ergodic critter
because look it's got these things
coming in like this if this was an
ergotic critter what would happen is
it would just be a single cycle with
everything on it that would be an
example of an ergodic that that's an
egotic discrete system this is not
that makes sense
and the i mean the the thing that's
tricky
is essentially every i mean this is now
i think not so relevant to what we're
talking about but you know essentially
the proofs
of the fact of how continuum behavior
comes out of discrete molecular dynamics
tend to depend on things like uh garlic
hypotheses
um but
they don't really depend on that
this is a long story this is irrelevant
i mean this is a whole story about
computational irreducibility and
observers and computationally bounded
observers and what you can assume about
randomness when you have a
computationally bounded observer of a
computationally irreducible process
but that's that's basically saying the
bottom line the net of that whole story
is
if the observer is computationally
bounded
then the things you observe when you
have a very complicated system that
builds up a whole bunch of stuff like
this
when you have a computationally bounded
observer
there are
you know there there are certain i claim
inexorable
features of what a computationally
bounded observer will observe
which can be deeply short-cut with
respect to all of that microscopic
dynamics
okay even though the description of the
model may involve describing the
microscopic dynamics
if all you want out
is
the result of a core strained
you know uh computationally bounded
observer then there is a faster way to
get that result than going through all
the microscopic dynamics
but if you want what if you want out is
you know what is the correct series of
moves to make for chemical synthesis to
get this particular output what is the
best path
for you know doing whatever then you
don't get to have those optimizations
you know essentially essentially the
claim is the laws of physics are an
optimization with respect to
multi-computation the laws of physics
are for purposes of a certain type of
observer
are
a dramatic
compression
of
all this multi-computational complexity
underneath
okay and what i'm imagining is going to
happen here
is that we are going to have a language
for the observer and that language could
say what i want out
is
the best path or the path that achieves
the skull or what i want out is the
probability distribution of all parts or
what i want out is this or that see what
i'm saying
and that observer
or or i might want out and this is again
something we're not just we haven't
described is the series of things the
time evolution of what you get from a
series of reference frames here are
defined as foliations of this multi uh
of this of this graph of this multi-way
graph
okay and so foliation is something where
you're making an equivalence class and
you're saying this this this and this
and this
those all correspond to the things i'm
sampling at this particular time
does that make sense
yeah but i mean
the reason why i was mentioning
i think you enlightened some stuff here
it's like there is a very deep
connection between the breaking of
ergodicity
uh
glossy transitions and np completeness
and so maybe we're actually on to
something here with no no i i understand
that well carlo you're right that the
way that okay so
if you want to think about it in terms
of of spin glasses for example okay
you can think about
uh
i mean in in you know an np problem
for example for a spin glass the ground
state of a spin glass
is to find the ground state of a spin
glass can be thought of as a you know as
an np problem np complete problem
actually
and that you can think about that
as you know you're flipping spins
deterministically you are treeing out
all the possible flippings of spins
and
the
the path the the one of those paths of
flipping spins in a certain way will be
the ground state that is roger's best
path here
and the fact that that best path is
a
the fact that that corresponds to an mp
complete problem
is
you know because that treeing out
is like a general
you know non-deterministic turing
machine a general multi-way turing
machine
that's really what what it comes down to
but what you have to do i mean you this
path just to remind people you know this
thing
is you know let's see if i can pull one
up
um
but the the the really interesting
like the physically interesting stuff
happens when the system itself has
trouble computing what the ground state
is and gets stuck of course
right
the physics does not win
look the
yes and the reason it gets stuck
is that okay so i mean
you know this question of does it flip
this way or that way eventually the
energy difference is
i mean yeah it's the same story as with
finding local versus global minima et
cetera et cetera et cetera when how how
do you do that you know can you find you
know by by saying let's say for example
we take gradient descent in this tree
right we say as we go through this tree
of possible configurations let's always
pick the branch of the tree that is
locally going downhill
that's essentially an implementation of
gradient descent in this sort of
semi-discretized system
and
we know that that will often not get us
to the the global minimum right instead
what we have to do often is we're going
down the tree and we have to backtrack
you know we could use simulated
annealing if we wanted to think about
probabilistically we backtracked up the
tree and then we keep going down again
and there will be a particular path that
is the winning path and that path will
not be findable necessarily by any
method that involves just local moves
if that makes sense
and it's the same problem so these are
non-deterministic these are these are
multi-way turing machines these are
turing machines that can make more than
one move at each step and again we have
this question if if we're doing a
deterministic computation can the turing
machine solve that you know what's the
you know what's the best state of the
turing machine there's one path that
gets that and we can ask the question
you know we can ask questions about the
probability distribution of turing
machine things etc
i i think
the um
uh
yes the the example of spin glasses
is a is a fine example
of where you can absolutely describe the
partition function of a spin glass in
terms of a set of moves about you know
flippings of spins and so on and you can
ask the question this is what's
interesting about multi-computation
is that in usually in statistical
mechanics all you say is we've got a
partition function for a spin glass
that's it and you say in the canonical
ensemble where you just have a
temperature there's a certain weighting
of the of the of the configurations of
the spin glass
what multi-computation is doing is it's
also talking about the time dynamics of
the system which is not something you
usually do i mean usually in a spin
glass the best you'll get into is global
dynamics or something
yeah but the the that's the exact like
some some features some physical
features cannot be described solely but
by the you know the the static of the
spin glass basically there is something
about the fact that the the system is
very hard to solve that shows up in the
physics and and this is the system
itself cannot do the computation yeah
yeah yeah right
work
yes that that's it's the same story here
i mean this is an exactly equivalent
setup and i mean by the way
yeah there's all kinds of examples of
this but but i think that's not i mean
you know the traveling salesman problem
is absolutely a fine example
of
well actually i'm not quite sure how
well formulated it is here but but you
know to just continue
sort of
my
vision of this so there are a set of you
know to me the question is can we
represent the set of moves by purely
symbolic transformation rules for
symbolic expressions but there are many
possible ways those rules could be
applied it's a replace list type story
right
so you know replace list could tell us f
of you know blank
i don't know what it is you know x x
blank x y double blank
um
you know that's that going to i don't
know
x y
and then we're saying replace list here
f of a b c d
you know that's giving us all the
possibilities there right
that's different from replace which just
picks the first possibility
why is this not finding more cases
am i confused here i probably need x
underscore underscore two oh yeah yeah
you're right
right okay there we go okay so that is
an example of a very trivial
multi-computational thing right it's
finding it's finding these many cases
right we don't have a replaced list that
goes all the way down through an
expression and part of the reason we
don't have that is we don't have a good
way to knit together those pieces
because what we're seeing here is this
is a way of knitting together i i think
i have some better examples somewhere
and i wish i had the previous some
previous notes we really should never
let this happen
of doing these meetings without previous
notes
um
really shouldn't let this happen
because we're wasting a huge amount of
time here
um well let me see if i can find um
i'm looking for
those are all
it's not interesting well it's gonna be
relevant in a minute but
well okay so here are some examples what
is this an example of
no this is still a one-to-many
transformation
are you looking for an idea of how to
specify that multi-evaluate here or
yes you're looking for an idea of
applications or what no no i'm looking
for design the objective is very
straightforward okay
although not easy i'm looking for a way
to specify multi-evaluate and
particularly this observer piece
that is a nice robust thing to do
that will let us achieve a bunch of
different goals here okay and right now
with this
what this is operating on this is saying
this is a bunch of transformation rules
and for example for combinators we know
what those transformation rules are
and we know what you know their
transformation rules for an ex for
expressions and what we're saying is we
want those transformation rules to be
applied in all possible ways those rules
in general will use more than one
expression at a time
do you see what i'm saying
right this these events don't
necessarily have to i'm really kind of
annoyed that i'm not finding
um although maybe this has some examples
here
uh okay well there's a there's a trivial
example of a token event graph
with i mean this is this is with token
event graphs which is not the right
formalism it's it's only part of the
formalism but here we've got you know
this is a two to one rule
see what i'm saying
and in general what should happen here
is that
what we're going to do is we're going to
say
these are the these are the states
and we're applying
in general these rules will say
well
let's see yeah yeah yeah this is this is
the issue the issue is
tokens okay
in this model in this setup
we are just looking at disembodied
tokens
okay
in general
what
transformationals that we have in the
system do
is they look at subparts of
expressions does this make any sense
let me try and give an example
okay
okay so here
we've got a um
a string replacement rule okay in this
string replacement rule bb goes to a
takes a sub part of that string and
replaces it
okay but the subpart of that string is
embedded in the whole string
am i making sense right whereas here
these tokens what we could do with this
string if we wanted to but it's very
unnatural is we could break that string
into a linked list
and every character is its own token and
everyone has its kind of connection
okay next to it do you get what i'm
saying
yep
okay
and and then we could use the same idea
that bb goes to a is two tokens going to
one token you see what i'm saying yep
that's rather unnatural it's not what
our pattern matcher does
our pattern matcher instead can take the
bb
conceptually that is embedded inside an
existing thing and make the
transformation on it
so the first question is how to get
the um
how to you know so that's what i'm
imagining
somehow there is a there's a you know
somehow there's a sea of expressions
that's being generated
and
the inits are an initial sea of
expressions and the rules are taking
subparts either from a single expression
or from multiple expressions and maybe
that's an incorrect way to think about
it maybe we just want the the uh us
always to think about well no i think
that's the right way to think about it
it's
it's by it's taking this multiple
subparts from different expressions and
those rules are saying this is the
transformation that's going to happen
right
we can think about that the multiple
subparts as tokens but those tokens can
either be
in
see one of the important things is that
you can have two different expressions
that are so swimming separately in this
set of expressions
and you can
combine them together by a rule to
generate a new thing
does that make sense
it sounds like you just want tokens to
the expressions
no
no no
no
no
no the whole point is tokens are
embedded
as they are in strings now you can say
oh in principle you can make a linked
list
right
but i'm saying i think there's another
idea that's needed that involves the
pulling out of tokens
from things that we we have the exact
same issue and theorem proving okay when
we state
the application of a theorem proving
rule we have to give this very ornate
way of saying you know in a theorem
proving rule when we apply it we have to
say it's applied to part number 231 of
this expression and part number whatever
of this other expression and then we
glue them back together in this way
okay now we could say
shatter those expressions into tokens
and then we don't have to say it's part
number 231 of this of this you know
expression it's just a token the problem
with that is
we have no idea where those tokens go
they're just free floating tokens
and we've lost a ton of information
so
let's look at it a little bit
does this make sense to people
do i should i give a more explicit
example of the of the theorem proving
case
would that be helpful
no i see what you mean
i mean the main problem is that it's
hard to turn expressions on the tokens
right but i mean you know even in
combinators right so let's remind
ourselves again are other people
following this or not because i want i
want to make sure people actually are
following
yes no maybe
yes
okay
okay so in combinators
you know very pure version of this
what we what we have are these weird
um
you know tree update events
uh where but what has to happen is i
know where we have an example of this
but but you know here we go this may be
some part of this these are these weird
pullback events
okay so this is so remember in a
combinator
you are making a transformation
uh
you know you take this tree
and the transformation rule and
combinator is an expression
and the transformation rule rewrites a
part of the tree that makes sense roger
everybody else you're on board you
understand what's going on yeah right
okay the tree that is rewritten
could be thought of as a token
okay the sub tree that is rewritten the
rewrite you know the combinator rule s
of x y z goes to whatever
is
that is essentially ingesting
three sub trees as
tokens
and it is producing four sub trees as
output four tokens as output
but it's very important that when those
tokens are ingested
they come they they come from a
particular place
and they are going to be reinserted back
into that place
they could be free-floating tokens but
then we have to have all kinds of weird
connectors that reattach them after
their rewrites
does that make sense max you understand
well so i can just refer to each other
that's more natural thing the way to
think about it
i don't think it's a more natural way to
think about it i mean that's what you do
in the case of look in the case of a
linked list okay you can represent
a
um
a string as a linked list
right
sure and
but in order to do that
the linked list has to do do people
understand this idea yes no maybe
let me let me show that idea
okay so this is
this is a bit more extreme but it's
basically the same idea so this is a um
this is a string transformation rule
okay
and in this case the string is being
represented by a hypergraph and rather
ornately
you know the b is a as a as a loop and
the a is a non-loop make sense to people
yes
no
people understand
do i pick on somebody and ask if you
understand
okay carlo do you understand
yeah i think so
okay so what's going to happen here is
there is a rule
that basically just talks about the but
but effectively there is a reattachment
every one of these
every node here
implicitly has a name it's a it's a
graph node it's not a node it's a hybrid
edge and the a is actually to the right
of the bottom
this is just a connecting vertex
okay fine so the connections between
letters in this case uh represent the
shared atoms in different tokens and so
this vertex in the middle that's a
connection between a and b
yes
there's one thing i'm confused about you
can definitely create a graph that
cannot translate to a string right an
hyper graph oh yeah absolutely
yeah this these are very special hyper
graphs that are specially built to be
like linked lists
right
and and i mean
the whole point is that
in a graph it is somewhat natural to
have these reconnectors
because we're used to the idea in a
graph that there are implicitly names
underneath okay so in an expression
we don't have that an expression we just
have this tree structure we don't name
the tree elements we just write them out
in the way that we standardly write out
a tree in a graph
under the hood there are names for every
vertex
right and so when we reattach into a
graph
there is a
you know we just have to name the vertex
and we say where to reattach
in a tree
you know we can say where to reattach by
giving a part number
but
it's but but the whole point is the
free-floating token
okay
a free-floating token and it reminds me
a little bit of the immune system and
other things a free-floating token could
in principle have an address on the side
of it
which says here's where to reattach me
okay and it may be that that's the right
conceptual way to think about this but
it sure isn't
it would be
well okay so the first issue is
when you are applying all possible
transformation you've got a collection
of expressions
and you're applying all possible trans
pattern transformation rules
and those transformation rules
could involve
subparts of more than one expression
does that make sense to people
do i need to explain that first yeah so
i
i feel that i understand i think i
understand where you're trying to go i'm
just can i try on you test it on you
yeah
so
if this wasn't rules you know if this
was like a non-deterministic finite
state machine
then we could still have an init which
could be a whole set or a single state
doesn't matter
then we haven't that what you call
observers what i would call output
equation
um
and but what is the what is evaluation
that's what i don't get is that like
it's okay so evaluation is the running
of the finite state machine but it may
never stop absolutely absolutely okay
this is a very important point
there's a very important point which i
was not mentioning yet and i've because
i forgot
okay
one feature of our current evaluation
scheme is that it uses normal forms
our model is there's input and there's
output
right
so x equals x plus one
just blows up in our current evaluation
scheme
okay the universe
we firmly hope at least for the time
being
doesn't terminate
right it's just an ongoing computation
and we are sampling that ongoing
computation now in our evaluation scheme
we have in one out one etc we have this
notion of
input crunch crunch crunch output
right
one of the features there are multiple
features of this multi-computation idea
that have to depart from our current
evaluation model
and one of them is
yes
that's the whole point that's the whole
point that's what this reference frames
thing is all about there are a series of
snapshots you can take
right in the universe there are a series
of time steps you know there's a series
of times at which you sample the state
of the universe
so similarly with your finite state
machine absolutely what one will be
asking for is not
you know is it does it go to an acceptor
state one might ask that that's one of
these cases absolutely
what is it
yeah what is it we want to ask for
well for example in a finite state
machine or let's say a petri net you
know one step up from a finite state
machine
automata which is buchi automata or
omega automata these are these that that
can go on forever
well i mean a finite state machine can
go on forever you just keep keep
circulating around i think that that
that that's yeah i think sure i mean
i think that that's what um i mean i've
i've used the term finite state machine
to represent the thing that i think
other people call booty automata okay
which is just just you know just things
without acceptor states right so they
just keep flapping around yeah so so
i've used those a bunch in like for
example in cellular automata there's the
following results in a one-dimensional
cellular automaton after t steps the set
of configurations that can be reached is
determined by the set of possible paths
through a finite state machine right
okay but you're trying to generalize
that finite state machine to expression
and transformation which has a similar
non-deterministic
character because they can apply it
multiple places exactly stuff that's
exactly right right so the whole point
is that okay you ask what do you observe
about the finite state machine what do
you observe about the petri net
so one thing you might what is it
what i mean what is
what is the out from this function what
is there that's the whole point there
isn't an out that's the whole point
that's why this is a paradigmatic
difference right there isn't an output
it doesn't work that way the observer
can observe some definite thing and can
deduce a definite thing from the
behavior of the system but the observer
doesn't say clink here's the output
right the the observer can have an
output from from the observer but the
system itself is specific
you're no i mean just
for me to test because observer means a
different thing in other contexts but i
think what you mean by observer is a
function of the state is that right yes
that is correct
but it might be that's normally called
output equation in control observer is
one that
actually given that what you call
observer or the output you try to infer
the state
just fine it's just fine i mean that's
no that's interesting but i mean i think
the point is that what i think is the
case in multi-evaluate
is that the
you know that observer function there's
probably a multi-evaluation it's
probably a multi-evaluate list or some
such other thing
which in which both one of them says
given this observer
i just want
this um
uh
uh you know
this kind of um
you know i want the the path with this
property clink one result right
another possible thing there
is oh so that observe
somehow that tells you when to stop then
if i find a path
yeah yeah exactly i mean look the whole
point is this you know a big part of
this story wherever i had those pictures
is um
i have those pictures
oh dear when i have those pictures i had
some
pictures
um
uh
oh i don't know where i put them
who knows
oh dear
that's what we've got right now okay so
what i was trying to show
was
um
maybe this
okay so
again another thing which we haven't
talked about properly is this notion of
causal graphs
because again in in what we do normally
we have a deeply impoverished view of
evaluation all we see is the input
ground ground grind the output we do not
see the update events that happen during
evaluation that was what trace tried to
do back in 1991
we haven't got a good way
of exhibiting you know what is the
series of operations that we do
in an evaluation you see what i'm saying
okay one reason why we have trouble
okay
is that unlike
a procedural language where there's a
program counter and where it's just
going through and it's got this state
this state this state this state
our notion of states is considerably
more complicated because of recursion
through expressions
does that make sense
yes
so you know what do you show as the
state
what you have as the state is both
the the here's this thing you know let's
say you have a procedural language it's
got four variables x x i j
k or whatever it is right the state is
just the values of those variables
but for us
the state and and the program counter is
just
grinding down but for us the state is
where did the evaluator get to in
recursing through this expression
among other things
and
and so in these
in this kind of representation
involving
here
we are kind of
showing
the actual evaluation the moment of
evaluation the event where something
happened right that's part of this data
structure here does that make sense
so part of the story and one of the
things that's come out of the physics
project is the importance of causal
graphs that
give the causal relationship between
successive events that turns out to be
an important thing but we have none of
that information in our current
evaluator
we're not storing that information we
don't care we're just going grind grind
grind down a particular path and saying
what the answer is why does one care
about these one one of the issues is
once there are multiple paths
for example the composition results that
you have are much more complicated
it's no longer the case that you can
just say it's this set of functions
composed with a set of functions it's a
more you know it's a whole giant
minority category story or whatever you
however you want to think about it
does this make sense
i mean in other words okay so the whole
point is there is an evaluation i think
we've looked at this before this is
super frustrating for me i it just
ridiculous
you know we've looked at this before we
talked about this notion of
computational objects and things where
we're actually storing this thing i
don't know where my notes about that are
and we really need to find that
um
and we're not making progress here i
mean what what i had wanted to do
was you know part of the story is
you've got one of these things here
and
you're you're asking what are some
reasonable
kinds of ways to foliate what's going on
here
does this make any sense
does anybody understand what i'm talking
about or is this hopeless
yeah definitely you're talking about
properties essentially
maybe look there's a because the
evolution object
let me let me let me be clear there's
several things that are wrong here okay
token event graphs are not enough
because they do not encode the
information okay in the case of the
physics project the tokens
are hyper edges of a hyper graph okay
and the information about which tokens
are ingested in an event
is not there is an additional piece of
information which is
how the tokens relate to each other to
make a spatial hypograph at a particular
moment in you know
for okay but that is a subtle position
that's actually contained graph because
tokens contain
only in that case do they contain the
tokens contain
the information because the tokens in
that case are hyper edges with named
you know elements
right
they know how to knit themselves
together
see what i'm saying
if they are fragments of expressions
they do not know how to knit themselves
together you know x plus y has no idea
how to knit itself to some other
expression
because it doesn't come attached with
markers on the side a hyperedge because
it is a hyperedge between
you know atoms between named elements
between named atoms it intrinsically
knows how to knit itself together
does that make sense right
whereas
a
a you know a random fragment of an
expression does not know that
right so we'd have to give it extra
wrapping to tell it how to do that
knitting that would be one possibility
one possible design approach i don't
think it's the right approach but it's
one possible approach
is that there are these
expression fragments like let's take the
example of the um
of the combinators you know we could
name in the combinator tree okay we have
your average combinator tree wherever
there's a combinator tree here i'm sure
i've got dominated trees there are some
there are some good combinator trees
okay
right now we are not naming
the
nodes in those combinator trees
do you see what i'm saying
all we're doing is we're saying let me
explain this because this is useful
thing to think about okay everybody who
everybody understand what this is yes
you understand what we're looking at
anybody not understand what we're
looking at
these are tree representations of
symbolic expressions that correspond to
combinators yeah
like is christopher
with us here
yeah i'm i'm here
and you understand what what we're
seeing here
yeah i think i know what those graphs
are
okay all right so the point is when we
make a replacement for a for a
subtree
all the numbering right now we are not
naming
the nodes in this graph
right they are just given tree numbers
basically they're just this is a
symbolic expression so
when we detach this this subtree
to ingest it in our rules
the reattachment is a complicated issue
we it doesn't that subtree doesn't have
a bunch of numbers for every element in
the subtree so what information is
contained in tokens in this case
because
this is just the root of that subtree
well i i yes you could say that but
again
then what you're saying is
one okay
we could make a token here that is
the representation of the root node
together with
its
tentacles you know it's numbered
tentacles that say how it connects into
the rest of the thing
right that will be the analog of the
hypograph case
i want to explain for people who haven't
been involved in the physics project the
next really complicated issue okay
the
the really comp let's say that we've got
a bunch of tokens right and we want to
knit those tokens together into a state
like let's take this example here we've
got different sub trees being rewritten
et cetera et cetera we've got a certain
set of events that have occurred
now we want to take
the token collection that exists at that
particular after those events have
occurred
and we're going to knit that back
together into a state
here's the tricky thing there isn't a
uni that that the question of which
events have happened is not a uni
there's not a unique ordering of events
right roger do you understand this point
so the issue is there can be let's take
even this picture here
these well i'm not even sure i have to
look more carefully but but my guess is
those two events are space like
separated
do you understand this idea
roger
are you with us roger
oh for goodness
sake
roger seems to have dropped
okay
i think this meeting may be doomed
okay do other people understand
christopher do you understand this this
idea about space like separated events
that is events that are not forced to
occur in a certain time ordering
they're anti-chains they're anti-chains
in the partial order right
and so the tricky thing is
that
the reconstruction of states is not
unique because it depends on
which
how you foliate
the causal graph
well what do you mean by the
reconstruction of states okay so the
tokens
are just hyper edges or in this case
they are roots of sub trees
okay
so
see what is this this might be the
notebook
that's not useful
i need to know
if james is giving me a notebook
direction i need to know the um
uh
this is this
no this is not the relevant this is the
notebook you're thinking of this is
not the relevant notebook i believe
well it's something
yeah it's part of it
i'm not sure
anyway the the the point that i'm making
is a state
like the state of this hypograph
is something that corresponds to a
certain
set of tokens
which can exist at the same time
if that makes sense
and is not the case that there's a
unique set of tokens that can exist
quotes at the same time it depends on
how you foliate this graph
right it depends there are many
different choices of sequences of
anti-chains
i think everybody is lost is everybody
lost
the whole point is look you've got a
bunch of hyper edges i think max at
least understands this you've got a
bunch of hyper yes
they were generated at different times
they were generated and the whole point
is you can you can make a foliation of
this of this
sequence of events
that
where you can say this set of hyperedges
can exist at the same time it is not
unique there may be a different set of
hyperedges that exist in a particular
time so it isn't the case that you can
say as you can in our usual evaluator
this happens then this happens then this
happens there are many different choices
that's essentially relativity
that is is telling you there are many
different choices of simultaneity
surfaces
one token might exist in multiple states
yes well that's true too but the whole
point is the knitting of tokens into
states
could be
okay
it could be the case
that it's an afterthought
okay that the that you've got all these
tokens and then later on you knit them
into states
later on you figure out how you're going
to observe them because the observer is
effectively making other equivalence
classes
does that make sense
when the observer is i mean statistical
mechanical version when the observer is
doing core screening the observer is
effectively making other equivalence
classes
um
i think there's some interesting
comments on our live stream here maybe
we should look at these
uh marco ask is a normal form black hole
yes it is
richard is saying for causal dependence
tracking you need to associate variables
and true false branches with those in
the condition
um
oh that that's commenting on the on the
if statements
uh
and the comment is there's a different
way of treating that for static versus
runtime analysis
i kind of think static analysis is
closer to our expression recursion and
runtime analysis is closer to the
reevaluation recursion
analysis of what
of these evaluation processes i mean in
other words
a static analysis sounds like you would
try to prove something from the rules
without trying the system
well it depends if you've got a straight
line if you've got a once through
program that doesn't have a loop in it
you can still have a whole nest of if
statements
where you know like a like one of those
you know galton board things where the
ball can go left or right at every step
you can still have many parts through
the f's
and
let's see
let's see marco is commenting on various
things about graph branchings
yeah satori is commenting basic month
computations about having a way to
describe parts of the multivariate graph
possible pattern matching yes that's
pretty much right
means ends analysis
yes i think that's related that is that
is the i don't i mean that term the
means ends analysis is is the same type
of story as we're talking about here
i think
um
so artoria's commenting
multi-computation for finding a good
decision tree
um
less so i think
let's see runtime instead of going one
transfer all the time you're looking
right so marco is commenting and it's a
pity roger has left that
that
um
the ndfa to dfa transition right is a
coarse graining transition
right so the people know the you know
the ndfa
the myhill nero theorem or whatever it
is the one that will translate from a
non-deterministic finite machine to a
dfa that is essentially a coarse
graining of state's story
because what you're doing is you're
taking course graining or equivalencing
different states together right
does that make sense
no does anybody understand this come on
i know people know how this ndfa to dfa
transformation works
should we try a visual example
no i mean people either know this so
they don't i mean i think christopher
certainly knows how this works yeah
yeah i mean i've seen this before at
some point
but the whole point is in an ndfa
right
what you have is
there are multiple possible
i mean
let's see if i've got an example i think
i might have an example from
things i was doing just recently let me
see if i can think of an example here i
think i might be able to do that with
well this may make a dfa
look the basic point is given a state of
a finite state machine the question is
with a given symbol can you get is there
just one way is there just one path with
a given symbol or there are multiple
parts it's the same thing as with a
non-deterministic turing machine if
there's a particular configuration of
the turing machine is there just one
next state or multiple next states and
the whole point is that for
finite state machines there's a
construction that allows you to
basically equivalence together
well you're yeah let's see how does this
work
i have to look it up in the the
well never mind it's probably not
relevant
okay
um
richard is commenting
okay i don't know what this is more
recent solvers use conflict-driven
clause learning i do not know what that
means
maybe with respect to um
uh sat solvers i don't know that i
thought that people were still using the
davis putnam thingy
um
oh this is an improvement in the
satisfiability algorithms
okay
that's kind of an interesting picture
there
of um
not sure how useful that is i mean
that's a
that looks like a theorem proving ish
way of doing sat solving
um
let's see
uh
super optimization riches comments and
and people optimization
which usually involves smt
right i mean that's optimal yes you're
right
if we could do things
you know super optimization and so on
involving you know just
flipping around machine instructions and
so on that is exactly the type of thing
that we would define rules for in fact i
know
that in a big uh
one
designer of microprocessor architectures
used our language
long long long ago to do essentially
symbolic transformations on
uh
on sequences of instructions and so on
using exactly that kind of idea
um
um
okay marco is commenting
okay incremental heuristic search i
don't know what that is in logic
programming it's very observer-like i
don't know what that is let me look that
up does anybody here know what that is
i don't know what that is i'm going to
make a note that's a thing to
study
um
let's see
equivalence marco is commenting
basically the problem of equivalence of
languages or grammars up to a certain
tolerance
yes that's a that's an interesting thing
to think about
that's an interesting thing to think
about although that's complicated
because
gosh
you know there isn't a good way we've
we've been interested in that problem
because we're trying to find
uh fast heuristics to determine for
example whether the wolf and alpha
parser can successfully pause something
um
let's see
okay richard is commenting
i have an edge rule apply rule
predicates
um
okay this is a comment i need to i need
to parse more carefully
uh
i have an edger rule and apply rule
predicate
applied on some logic programming
databases an initial state
there are abstract machines i'm only
using graph rewriting okay so and um
richard is is pointing us to reference
here about implementing logic
programming
languages by graph rewriting yeah i mean
so
that may be related to
a lot of stuff that's been done
on um
uh
[Music]
let's see what we've got here
oh dear
there's a file and a dot gz dot
psd
format oh look at this very convenient
seems to be a book about
implementing logic programming languages
by graph rewriting
okay i wonder what this is about that
might be relevant to us sounds
potentially relevant
um
graph rewriting
okay term rewriting systems i mean graph
rewriting people often talked about this
in terms of
for combinators and so on
what the heck is all this
okay this looks relevant
okay that's term rewriting
okay those are expressions
yeah so i mean this may be what we were
saying before
namely
you are rewriting graphs see see the
advantage of graphs and hypergraphs over
standard tree-like expressions is you
can always after you do any
transformation of a hypergraph you can
always re-glue the result back into the
hypograph
whereas
well it's particularly bad for an
expression if you are taking two parts
of the expression
it's completely unobvious that the new
piece that you get from those two parts
can be re-glued yeah that's a good point
actually well what what what
by what mechanism would you specify the
two parts are being are being taken
together where you're not basically just
saying that
the single super expression is being
transformed
well i'm just saying that you can take
two
pieces two distant pieces
okay let's imagine we have a soup of
expressions we have a thousand
expressions and we're going to pick
pairs of them to make transformations on
that will be an example
i mean like like what's happening here
it's a number of outputs so we need to
be the same as number of inputs
so that
because why
no if you're going to reach forever
no but the whole point is look
when
when you do a transformation
particularly on multiple output or
multiple inputs
and you get a different number of
outputs
how do you
reseat
you know the outputs back into the
places where the inputs came from
right well you can create new
expressions which are not connected to
anything i i know but that's not what we
want to do that's the whole point we're
losing something here because our
standard evaluation
we might want to do
right we still need to put
the sub expressions back i mean
something needs to be there
even if it's
exactly one symbol
right so the whole point is for for
hyper graphs
this or even graphs
yeah this
we delete old expressions
i know but the problem of how to reseat
is solved
because you know how the thing connects
this problem
we delete old ones and we create new
ones
same same difference we know how to
re-knit them back into a state
whether the state has all new fresh
other hyper edges doesn't really matter
we still know the new hyperedge we know
how to connect it into the existing
hyperedges
sure but i think it's a separate issue
because with the hyperaction we can just
delete it and it doesn't break anything
with an ex with a sub expression we
can't just delete it
that's good it's going to be the same
issue if you had hyper graphs where you
know the vortex degrees you fixed
to you know twos like three yeah fair
enough fair enough fair enough okay
right for in a hyper graph we can just
delete an edge and it'll still be a
perfectly good hyper graph
and all will be okay
you know i think that's one of the
reasons when i was doing trivalent
graphs that's one of the issues that i
mean that's one way to state what are
the issues
i mean this this wouldn't work eg in a
trivalent graph
in a trivalent graph there's a lot more
constraints on what you can delete and
so on
right
um
carlos said something about zippers
what is this this is just what is this
what is this that thing zipper is uh
basically it's the data structure that
comes out when you're trying to traverse
a data structure so basically if you
have a
you're traversing a list the zipper of a
list is two lists the one on the left
and the one on the right of the cursor
what is it for a tree
well it's funnily enough it's the
derivative of
the tree
in the type system sets
but it's it usually ends up if it's a
binary tree
it's two trees basically
what is the relationship between zippers
and tracelets anybody got any idea
um i haven't heard that term before
so your claim is that the
zipper is a derivative of a data
structure
in some sense it's the type derivative
of a data stream
i'm sorry yeah
yeah the way to think about it is that
if you look at uh if you think that a
list is like uh
it's like a series right
you can sum it
and and
and basically you you have this
relation that looks like uh the
uh
the geometric series
yeah right okay yeah one over one minus
a or a is the type and so basically you
can drive with respect to the type way
which is the the piece that you're
removing
and you get you get two lists basically
which is left and the right and you can
do this for binary
so one way you could think about a
zipper then if you if you use a zipper
as input
it is like
replace
part replace part or something
a zipper is telling you like in our
theorem prover okay what's the
relationship to the theorem proverb
in other words is a proof
you know is a zipper
like a proof
as in
that the sequence of things that you
change to get to the result and you
could imagine feeding the zipper back in
again and saying these are the places to
do the replacements at
does that make sense
i'm not sure i mean it's
as far as i understand zipper it's much
simpler thing like you're you're doing
string substitutions you have to if
you're doing something in the middle and
you look at the string as a as a linked
list you have to keep both the left part
of the list and the right i understand i
understand that that's what's being said
here but i'm i'm sort of generalizing
that to say this is the trace
of what
you know of where you did things
yeah okay
yeah
okay the port graph okay what richard is
saying in logic programming his logic
programming approach the initial state
is immutable it says an edge exists at
time t if if rule applies t minus one
reply to t minus one if the edge exists
at t minus two
okay
yup
the port graph framework okay this is
another thing that i don't know what it
is
um
i have to look those things up
um
uh marco saying the tokens represent the
space time you followed no that's not
really right the tokens represent pieces
which you knit together to make space
[Music]
um let's see
richard is commenting and the nfa to dfa
is a power set construction
where you get multi-states
yes
um
[Music]
what do rules look like in
multi-evaluate replacement rules yes
they just look the same as i think my
current thought is
but this is where i'm confused about the
re-gluing of expressions that they look
just like current transformation rules
look
um
let's see marco's commenting we get the
same result as combinators by doing
stream writing i don't quite think so
maybe they're with parentheses i'm not
sure maybe max knows that
oh and richard's commenting port graphs
you can have labeled oh okay then i know
what you're talking about yes oh yes i
worked on those extensively before we
invented the kind of hypograph idea
there are
you know
they are
not as clean as hypergraphs in my
experience
um
but it's basically you you end up with a
situation where
um
i mean to give an example
if i'm not mistaken and we haven't
really followed these
particularly
um
and some whole giant can of worms here
from 2006 it looks like and these things
here where you have that this is i think
what you're talking about
these are these are graphs where every
where instead of the note instead of the
edges being just oh i'm just an edge
connected to this node it's like around
every node there is a naming of
directions so to speak
and
the main conclusion of this is it's very
similar to what we're doing now but it
was just a little bit messier
i mean these are in between expressions
and ordinary graphs
um
what do you mean by that
well expressions also have labeled ports
because you have a headless label
sub-expressions
but they're also trees this one don't
have to be trees but they're also not
completely structures
i wonder whether that actual copy works
oh my gosh look at that
time warp
um
let's see
ratio is common in hyper graphs is
bipartite graphs where partitions for
vertex
vertices and edge vertices yes yes yes
yes that that is
that i think is the same kind of thing
as we have in these token event graphs
where they're they're the event
nodes and they're the token nodes
look the stuff i'd hope to get to and we
are running out of time here
is um
unfortunately this didn't quite go the
way i was hoping it would go
um so it goes we're still in an early
phase for this project
the um
what i really want us to think about
is well the re-gluing problem
the re-gluing of things back into that's
one thing
the question of what it is what the
language of
of samplings is
and then how do we write optimizers
given i mean so so in other words
one thing we could do
is to say
let's get a computation object that
represents a giant token event graph
that's all been worked out that is
completely impractical for most cases
what is realistically going to happen is
pieces of that graph may be generated
but then based on what we actually want
to pull out with the observer we'll end
up with vastly different actual
computations that we do underneath does
that make sense to people
well the really two pieces here is one
which parts parts of that graph you want
to compute
and the second which property of that we
want to extract
yes but some of you are independent
um
maybe
i don't know if we're trying to
construct do probabilistic programming
we're trying to construct a distribution
over all results
right let's say we want to compute a
distribution over states
not tokens but states a distribution
over states
then
i don't know what we compute it's kind
of complicated to know what we compute
that's a whole graph computation but an
approximate one
yeah
and you probably want to do sampling in
some kind of clever way yeah you want to
do some kind of monte carlo important
sample type thing probably
um
whereas
you know but but
the thing that i i guess i was
particularly interested in also
is
what is a plausible foliation right so
there are there are these are total
orderings but those are foliations right
and and there are different
you know they're different
that's a foliation for example right
that's a particular way of of deciding
how to sequentialize a series of events
making sense
one question is how to describe these
foliations
right so in other words if we have a
family of foliations how do we describe
it
okay in relativity we have things like
inertial frames
that's a description of a foliation of
space-time
the question is what to do in this case
where we have these different possible
is this making any sense
i mean how do we describe it when we
before it's computed
yes how do we describe which foliation
we want like i want the inertial frames
i want an accelerated frame i want this
whatever that's that's what we could be
describing in a spatially you know in a
system where we can lay out the tokens
you know where where
again it's a little complicated because
the branch-like separated versus
space-like separated but in the pure
like case we're essentially laying out
tokens in space
and we're asking
or laying out events in space and we're
asking
which
events do we want to say
you know
what is the ordering in which we are
going to consider the events to be
to
you know to happen
right and that's going to be relevant
in you know if we want a multi-evaluate
list
that's going to tell us that the time
evolution and by the way for things like
x equals x plus 1 or a non-terminating
combinator expression
or i claim a bunch of things of
relevance to microbiology
immunology a bunch of other areas this
this dynamic thing of what is the
structure of this graph
evolving over time
is
kind of important right that that's the
thing we want but it is evolving over
quotes time
where time is defined by some foliation
but we have to say
we have to have a description language
for those foliations
does that does that make sense
yeah
yes i think so
right so
in in general relativity that will be a
a gauge
right that's that's what you would call
the foliation
is you know you have a a shift and lapse
what is it shift vectors lapse vectors
whatever
which are which determine how you map
points at one moment in time into points
at another moment in time
and so the question here is what are
reasonable ways
to do that specification
just like like for example we have a
very coarse thing we do we have a
recursion limit right if you recurse x
equals x plus one enough we just say
oops we're stopping i don't even know
what the front for the recursion limit
looks like that is if you have a
complicated marks generation
it is yes it's something like that
right
but i mean
this
you know
this this is
right so generations are one concept for
a foliation
by a generation
we mean
a maximal subset a maximal anti-chain
if that makes sense
a maximal subset that can be
simultaneously done
right
generation is a number
no no no but the definition of what a
generation what is in a generation what
events
happen in a generation
right in order to do that if you take
all
tokens actually no it wouldn't
necessarily be maximum subset
[Music]
you might have leftover tokens from
previous generation
fine okay but there's a definition
right so i mean that's a definition for
a generation number
okay but but look look
look so i mean the the
foliations
so one example is generations
that's one type of foliation
um
the event order in this case would be
you know monotonically increase in
generation
which is a class of event or this
okay but then so okay so we can talk
about foliations as
basically their event orderings
but so what was a little bit more than
that because event ordering
so you know that's a total creations uh
a list of lists of events
right
that would that would give a total order
but what we want is a partial order
right
by the way another related thing with
foliations is breadth first search
and the different variants of breadth
first search
um
let's see
iterative deepening is a foliation with
respect to some heuristic that is a
function of the state okay i've never
heard of iterative deepening
richard you you come up with just a lot
of terms that are very useful to us and
very interesting i don't i'm not aware
of these things
okay so i can guess what iterative
deepening might mean
as a function of the state determines
the order of visitation of a nodes in a
search tree
so things like ida star which i don't
know what that is but well a star i
understand i don't know what ida star
means should find the lowest cost path
is kind of a least action least
computation principle
that's interesting
so okay so iterative deepening
the the concept would be okay
so that i see i understand the idea so i
mean that's basically a what are you
going to you know i.e here that so what
are you going to compute next
where are you going to
where are you going to advance
the evaluation front next
that makes sense
first of all the most general way to do
it is to feed a function that takes a
partial
evolution object
and tells you
where to compute next yes obviously but
the whole point is the whole point of
language design
is to come up with a version of this
that isn't absolutely incomprehensible
right i mean you know
um
uh
christopher do you have any great ideas
for how to specify these things
not really
do you at least understand the point
i mean aren't there like just a massive
number of these yes there are yes there
are and the whole point is that this is
but just like there are massive number
of operations you can do on lists
and you might just say there are massive
number of operations there are a massive
number of ways to rearrange a list well
but like you sort of need to
let me see
i mean if
you sort of need to be able to refer to
expressions that don't exist yet don't
you
yeah i i agree i think that's part of
the problem
you need to be able to but i think you
might say the same thing about lists
about lists you know
like well no because you do one
operation and then you have the stuff
you know you the expressions exist and
then you do things with them
fair point so what we're saying here is
well if you have a function like yours
in advance
it doesn't know yet like when you define
the your's function doesn't know yet how
many elements are going to happen you
can still do it
that's true
so i mean there's special cases of event
orders which are easy to define ahead of
time
such as
well such as you solve by generation
first and then by
like by age of a token or something
right
right by age of a token means
you you have a generation is just a tick
of the clock
and you go through and you
you have some ordering of tokens right
you have to have an ordering of tokens
you say let me go through and consume as
many tokens as i can
first of the oldest tokens and so on
right yeah yeah basically one way to do
it is that you have some sorting
criteria like generation you know age
event number and so on i mean event
index
rule index
and you know other things like this
and then you specify a list of the
certain criteria
by priority
right
they basically you sort tokens then
then consume the first ones or something
yeah
so you generate an ordering on tokens
and then you consume some
right
well you're
you're generating generating ordinary on
events not tokens
oh well that's right yeah right right
right right
well but but no
tokens
which then lead to which can be involved
in certain events
because these are events
you know you sort events because tokens
will like if you want to sort by rule
index for example it has nothing to do
with tokens at all i know but but but
the whole point is on a given branch
if we're not
talking about branch-like separated
things
the set of all possible events
contain many events which are
branch-like separated that cannot
simultaneously happen
right so we could imagine if we're doing
a multi-way
you know
thing we we can generate all possible
events
including ones which cannot
simultaneously cannot in the same branch
of history occur
and then we could do a sort of all of
those
but yeah but there's a different issue
which is in a single branch of history
we
i think we're more like sorting tokens
um
well no because you can still have
things like rule index
in a single history
yeah not to mention you can have
well when you have multiple tokens
sorting sets of those tokens it's more
complicated than such individual tokens
because for example how do you
distinguish between say one three five
and well one
four five and two three five or one four
and two three
richard is commenting here about using
look ahead some parsers need to look
ahead some number of symbols
globals i don't know what those are
usually i know about la you know la lr1
and so on pauses oh i see these make
porous forests exploring all possible
derivation trees
and then using user provided
disambiguation rules okay so that's so
that's a good point that's a good
example that's another example is
parsers are another example where
essentially precedence etc um precedence
precedence gives one
um
gives one to something you know gives
one a a
a it's not a foliation gives one an
ordering basically on transformations
right which transformation do you do
first
that's an interesting case because a
parser in general can have lots of
ambiguity which is dis
disambiguated
by
by things like precedence
i believe
um
well we should probably i mean look
christopher your comment i mean
basically what we're looking for
is a
parametrization
of evaluation fronts
aka
i mean do you want everyone or do you
want no no i want the ones that we care
about
i want i want a language for describing
evaluation fronts that matter
just like
you know
in principle one could do any you know
you've given a list of size n by m where
those aren't specified you could do any
transformation you want on that list you
could i mean it's like i suppose
permutations would be a good example of
a case where you could do anything
but the question is which permutations
do we care about and maybe with
permutations that's not a great example
although we might think about
permutation groups and things like that
where there are permutations we care
about so to speak
well maybe i mean there is a most
general version which could handle
everything which is like you give it a
function and the function just you know
it it looks at all the the
tokens available at any given moment and
it decides what it's going to
you know which rule it's going to apply
or something like that so that's like
the most general which probably gets all
the foliations
and then after that i don't know i mean
maybe
i mean i just don't know what the useful
i mean certainly depth first breath
first or useful
uh i don't know which others really like
i don't know any use case for any others
well but that's why things like the
whole point is we're generalizing beyond
just getting
those are just
total orderings
we're saying some of the observers here
don't get
a
you know the objective of breadth first
search is ultimately to just get a
result
you know by a certain ordering so you're
using a total ordering and you're going
to as soon as you have a winner you're
done
whereas here i'm saying there are other
forms of output that you might want
that involve describing the ongoing
computation
rather than just the you know the winner
so to speak
i mean this is still
yeah i mean
um
well look i i mean i haven't yeah right
i mean i think i think it's probably
worthwhile to to look a little bit more
at these goals
ah boy
carlo do you have any other thoughts
you know it's nearly 1am for me so
okay so
you've you've almost reached a normal
form for the day
yeah you can see that
um it sounds ominous
uh
anyway all right
well
well look thanks and thanks people on
live stream particularly richard and
marco who've had all kinds of
interesting things to say
um the uh
um
right well we should play wrap up for
now and uh
we will continue another time
thanks much everybody